aller
[Musique]
chercher les nom plus tellement visible
le numéro est complètement effacé donc
c'est fout avec ça je ne peux pas vous
je peux pas voter donc il y a nécessité
d'obtenir un duplic je ne peux pas voter
sans cette carte visible par rapport au
ces
précédentes cette carte là a un vrai
problème moi là je depuis que je l'ai
pris je l'ai jamais
utilisé
les nouvelles cartes avec la nouvelle
imprimante elle ne s'effacee pas on est
confiant tout le monde aura sa carte
avant le
[Musique]
la personne c'est e de dire qui il y a
physique
[Musique]
à l'Ô du 20 décembre ça devient
inquiétant si nos Observateurs
n'arrivent pas à obtenir des cartes et
que la sénie arrête les processus
euh de
d'accréditation ça serait regrettable
quand même pour notre
processus voilà j'ai j'ai une grande
dévotion à la Vierge Marie là la Vierge
je Marie vous avez la
Bible la loi ne nous autorise pas de
publier les résultats à la place de la
sénie et comme mission d'observateur
nous devons euh nous limiter à dire si
Cees résultats publiés par la sénie sont
conformes à la vérité des urnes tel que
nous avons observé et encore Fatir que
la SNIE comprenne que euh ce qui reste à
faire est fondamental donc l'affichage
au niveau des bureau de vote et qu'on
laisse la laattitude aux
observateurs le faire nous espérons que
l'administration de Kadima sera ouverte
à échangé avec
nous par rapport au résultats que nous
aurons
[Musique]
eu
je crois que l'importance que le peuple
congolais accorde à la mission
d'observation de la Senco se justifie
par le fait que elle a tout la
population congolaise a toujours vu
l'Église catholique à Cees côté même au
moment difficile de l'histoire donc
l'Église a toujours accompagné euh la
population
congolaise comme ten du gouvernement euh
dans l'éducation dans la santé et on est
présent
[Musique]
partout
alléluia
Saint-Esprit
[Musique]
Dieu
ya
[Musique]
mokozia
Yu